my name is Stuart halacha and I'm a
rerecording mixer three things I think
you need to succeed in my job are an
absolute love of the industry the hours
are so demanding you need to be able to
just you know really stick at it you
also need a fair amount of technical
ability and most importantly i would say
an understanding of storytelling a sound
recording mixer that basically takes the
dialogue the music and effects and users
mixing desk to combine them in life your
ear can tune in to what you need to hear
in a film or a TV program it doesn't it
needs to be guided and it's my job to
ensure that you are listening to what
you should be listening to at any given
time the creative decisions about what
you can hear it only one time are
obviously and it's based on a number of
influences the director and editor who
have come up with stuff while they're
cutting the film and probably actually
you need script stage they will have
ideas but things evolve and it's my job
to take on their ideas to listen to
their ideas but maybe adapt them into
something that is workable given what we
have
basically the process of what i do i
often get sent scripts and I
intentionally avoid reading them because
I just know from experience that what is
in the script invariably isn't what's on
the screen I would much rather respond
to the cutting copy so I tend to get
involved at a point where the film is at
least assembled so I have the output
from the cutting room effectively at
that point I then assess the dialogues
to see if there's any problems if
there's things that need to be 80 yard
and then I will talk to the effects
editors who will also had spotting
sessions with the directors and we will
have a very collaborative attempt at
come up with ideas many of which would
be thrown out but a few live to the
final mix then the director and
potentially editor come in and we start
pre mixing and we basically build the
mix-up in in stages we start with the
dialogues we had the effects and then
eventually put music in I think the
biggest challenge in harry potter and
the deathly hallows was actually twofold
the first part had very little sort of
explosive action in it it was a very
gentle road movie and that presented
challenges in terms of creating an
atmosphere holding an audience and
making sure that the whole thing told
the story held together David Yates is
absolutely dedicated to telling stories
and anything that compliments the
storytelling is embraced immediately
anything that works against it is just a
no-go you just don't don't do that stay
stay on target with the story the second
part was a very different affair the
second we looked at it we knew that it
was full of action it was loud it was it
was just constantly moving so our
challenge was to ensure that it had
enough range in it but it wasn't just a
barrage of sand that it was all so quiet
gentle to allow this explosive moments
to happen
and I think they got there I wouldn't
mind having another guy owed a couple
bits but um but i'm quite happy with
most of it
I think the most exciting thing for me
about the job is that I and there when
the film is complete for the first time
I have the finished picture usually and
I have the complete soundtrack so it's
sort of it's the point where all the
elements that have been worked on for
maybe two years three years come
together and they are a cohesive film
that an audience will get to see I think
one of my favorite moments was the snake
attack in deathly hallows part one and
the reason I love it so much it's such a
it's a sound cliche it's a very quiet
moment that becomes extremely loud very
quickly but to sit in a cinema and watch
that's quite far back actually the
casting crew screening and watch 2,000
people jump you know it's coming but
just see them all jump and the reason
they jump is it's not just because of
the picture it's mainly because of a
sound and and that was a real thrill and
I couldn't help laughing actually
you